It’s truly a magnificent feat to have an
ensemble of outstanding characters each
with intriguing characteristics and inner
conflicts, to then completely destroy the
vast majority of them by the end of the show. And
David and Dan, the showrunners of Game of Thrones,
somehow managed to do it. So for this video, we
are going to be ranking the top ten characters
that David and Dan ruined the most and it’s
not like there wasn’t a lot to choose from.
Number 10, Euron Greyjoy. Honestly, I really
didn’t know where to place Euron and if I
should have even included him on this list to
begin with. Because the thing about show Euron
is that he was bad from the get-go. While every
other main character on this list was at one point
an outstanding character who you loved dearly.
But Euron on the other hand definitely doesn’t
fit that description. His entrance was laced with
juvenile satire and he wasn’t this menacing and
terrifying figure he was supposed to be. Which
is the main reason why I’m including him on this
list because his book counterpart is a drastic
upgrade from the show version. I made an entire
video about this talking about the many issues
of Euron Greyjoy and how to fix his character.
The main points were his lack of impact in the
story, his inconsistent goals and motivations, the
weird cartoonish character direction, and how his
constant usage of annoying comedy was a detriment.
Show Euron is basically an entirely different
character from his book counterpart and just from
that alone I think deserves him a spot on this
list. He may not make you as upset from how bad of
a character he is since he was never good, but the
potential was extremely high for him to be great.
Number 9, Jaime Lannister. This may seem like
Blasphemy that I’m putting Jaime so low on this
ranking, but keep in mind, he was only ruined
during his final episode. Up until that point he
genuinely had some good development and I think
his season 7 arc was the best thing about that
season. So at least he doesn’t have multiple
seasons worth of development that makes him
an atrocious character. And instead just one
episode. Now I used to really hate how Jaime
said that he didn’t care for the innocents,
but this could also be interpreted as Jaime
using his Kingslayer persona to come across
as being more tough and pushing himself down
this hateful path that he’s suddenly on. The
bigger issue to me that still ties into this
terrible line is that the writers are taking his
character into a direction that regresses him and
undoes his character growth. I think it would
have been perfect to have a mad king mirror in
that Cersei was contemplating destroying
the city and Jaime is forced to kill her,
thus he sacrifices another thing he loves
which is his sister. Losing his honor, skill,
and love for what is right. Not him suddenly
going back to her despite being appalled by
her and dying while trying to flee on a honeymoon
getaway. It makes the Brienne love scene feel like
fan service because he abandons her within seconds
after having sex. Surely he should know the fate
of Cersei by this point. It fundamentally feels
like a failure to the character’s ending when you
can read any other rendition of it and probably
like it significantly more. He’s supposed to have
this addiction to Cersei, but that was the entire
point of his season 7 arc in that he overcame her
toxic grasp and moved on to do good things.
But whatever, I guess the writers disagree.
Number 8, Daenerys Targaryen. Like Jaime
Lannister, you’d probably assume that she
should be further into this list, but she really
wasn’t that bad up until David and Dan decided
to cram an entire mad queen arc in the span of
like two episodes. Or really just one episode
because before this she was perfectly happy. An
entire arc that should be at minimum an entire
season long fundamentally doesn’t work in just a
single episode. You lose out on all the detail,
slow and believable build-up, and it’s as if David
and Dan are forcing Dany’s character to bend and
break into something she’s not. That’s why you
need to take time to slowly progress her to
this mad state instead of it literally happening
overnight. She has shown signs of being ruthless
and cold in the past, but her reasoning was always
that these were bad people and she cared about the
common folk. I can go into a plethora of issues
as to why the whole scenario of her snapping
is so devoid of logic, but we already know the
dense layer of dogshit writing that submerges her
character here. It completely lacks common sense
and utterly disconnects you from the character
because you have no idea why she’s destroying the
entirety of Kingslanding when she already won and
should only care about Cersei. So when there’s a
glaringly obvious fix for the writing in having
Rhaegal die during the battle of Kingslanding thus
driving Dany to go crazy and act irrationally in
the moment, makes me think that David and Dan
had no idea how to execute the mad queen arc.
Because as it stands, there was nothing to
drive her over the edge during that moment
and I don’t know why she was showing so much
restraint up until that point. Such a simple
change could have fixed multiple major errors
in the script and it’s just mindboggling to me
that they let this happen. Daenerys because of
this has such a contrived ending and when she
inevitably dies you barely feel anything
from how compromised her character was.
Number 7, Arya Stark. Now Arya Stark as a
character I think is pretty much intact and
her overall persona I think is fine within
the later seasons of the show. The primary
issue is that David and Dan had no idea how to
utilize her within the story. Because in season
7 her entire conflict was about questioning and
challenging her sister which was pretty wild and
felt contrived throughout, and then in season
8 she basically had nothing to do. That’s why I
primarily believe that David and Dan gave her the
Night King to kill as a consolation prize because,
besides that, she doesn’t use any of her faceless
assassin skills. Let alone even using them to
kill the Night King. It makes an entire two
season chunk of her journey feel absolutely
pointless because she practically has no
payoff for what she went through. That’s
like watching Rocky train for an entire hour
and then he decides to become a bird watcher
in the end. The fact that Jon or anyone don’t
bring up that she can simply assassinate Cersei
with her unique skillset during any meetings
is maddening. It sidelines her character and
shifts the spotlight onto Jon and Dany as
they hash out such a jerry-rigged conflict
that makes no sense. Arya’s circumstances is so
heartbreaking from how much of a fan-favorite
character she was and how underutilized
she has been since the end of season 6.
Number 6, Jon Snow. David and Dan handling
this character is honestly really depressing
because he becomes so dull and shallow through
their writing. The second he’s resurrected it
feels like he’s just a tool to carry out
the plot and all personality has left the
character. Even the internal conflict of being
a Targaryen is so half-baked because David and
Dan barely explore it to a good extent, and the
dialogue they write for him is terribly basic
and repetitive. So much to the point that it's
become a meme about how much he says muh queen
and I don’t want it. But even just developing
the character feels largely skipped over as
key scenes like the reveal and him telling his
sisters are extremely rushed. Or just flat out
not included. So since the most interesting aspect
of his character is so neutered and downplayed,
it in turn makes him very uninteresting.
Along with the character literally dying
and being brought back to life, but David
and Dan treat that as a get-out-of-jail-free
card instead of a major act that fundamentally
changes him. Forget about how Beric Dondarion
says that dying and coming back from the dead
drastically changes you. There’s so much under
the surface for Jon Snow to be expanded upon
that it’s just sad that David and Dan don’t go
there and rush the story to the point of making
him a generic gooddoer with barely any depth.
Number 5, Cersei Lannister. Speaking of characters
that used to be really deep and complex, Cersei
Lannister is basically a husk of what she used
to be in the earlier seasons. Primarily because
David and Dan give her nothing to do in the final
seasons. At the absolute bare minimum, she has
Jaime in season 7, but once he leaves, season 8
Kingslanding is like a barren wasteland for any
developments or characters. We have Bronn who’s
legally not allowed to have scenes with Cersei,
Qyburn who basically has no characterization,
a brick wall, and a horny cartoon pirate. Pick
your poison! The selection of people for Cersei to
talk to is practically non-existent and it’s very
apparent that David and Dan should expand upon
Kingslanding for the sake of Cersei’s character
instead of deflating it. Because by stripping
Kingslanding down to nothing, that in turn does
the same for Cersei. She has no personal or minor
conflicts to overcome, no one to express herself
to, and thus nothing to change and develop
her. Like is she running the entire kingdom
by herself? Does she have a new small council?
How is she manipulating the masses into loving
her despite killing thousands of them? She’s the
literal queen of Kingslanding which in turn breeds
so much conflict and it’s completely unexplored.
Cersei used to be a POV character back in season
5 and 6 and it seems like David and Dan stripped
her of that title for the sake of rushing the show
to its conclusion. Lena Heady deserved much better
than staring out of windows for most of season 8.
Number 4, Varys. When we're at the point where
the actors playing the characters are clearly
upset with their direction, then you know
were down bad. Varys was a mysterious and
intelligent man who always operated in the
shadows and had a major role in the biggest
events of the show. He had great importance
and was a lovable and unique character who
had amazing and deeply engaging dialogue scenes
with an equally smart character. After season 4,
Varys becomes a punching bag for Tyrion’s
barrage of annoying jokes and basically
just becomes a background messenger. Looking
through the entirety of seasons 5,6,7, and 8,
the only scene that half resembles him is when
he manipulates that random girl working for the
Sons of the Harpy for information. Other than
that, he does fuck all and may briefly chime
in for some exposition here and there. Gone are
his great discussions with Tyrion, the aura of
mystery surrounding his character and what he’s up
to, and any impact he had on the plot. He spends
the entirety of season 7 doing nothing and adds
no value to team Daenerys. Like I understand he
left behind his little birds in Kingslanding,
but if the man was able to order assassination
attempts on Dany all the way in Essos, then
surely he should know basic information like
enemy troop movements. Then for his final outing
they have him suddenly switch his allegiance to
Jon despite him being completely devoted to Dany
for almost the entire show. Dany is rightfully
upset that she lost her best friend and one
of her children and Varys is immediately like,
she might be a mad queen everyone abandon ship.
So Varys acts dumb for the sake of scheming and is
killed for it. What a waste. Varys is the epitome
of being swept under the rug and being forgotten
about and is another unfortunate casualty of David
and Dan not knowing what to do with a character.
Number 3, Bran Stark. So for Bran, I can buy
the fact that he is a dull husk of a human,
but there are two major things that David and Dan
destroy about him. Firstly and most importantly
is the fantastical elements surrounding Bran.
This is a character who has proven that he can
manipulate the past and essentially travel in
time, and is omniscient. It’s still a little
confusing to me about how that aspect works
but he does imply at the end of the show that
he can see into the future. So the fact that we
have a character that is this busted in terms of
strength and is never utilized is outrageous to
me. The whole season 7 conflict with Sansa and
Arya should be non-existent because of this and
so should many other conflicts as well. Along
with literally introducing time travel and it
never coming back up again. Bran should of had
some major manipulation in terms of the outcome
of the story, but from our perspective he just
waits on the sidelines to become king. For all we
know he did manipulate things in the background,
but we’ll never know for sure. It seems like that
would be such a cool reveal that Bran is actually
the most evil person in the show for allowing this
catastrophe to happen, but then this leads into
his other glaring issue in that his motivation is
very inconsistent. He has said multiple times that
he doesn’t care about anything, and then seemingly
he does care deeply about creating a prosperous
realm at his rule. His character just doesn’t make
any sense and I haven’t even gone into the fact
that David and Dan skipped over an entire season
worth of build-up for his character. Imagine being
that lazy that you don’t include a main character
in an entire season of your show, holy shit.
Number 2, Littlefinger. Funnily enough,
Littlefinger has an extremely similar
fate as Varys does in terms of how David and
Dan handled his character. What was once one
of the smartest and most cunning characters in
the show devolves into a glorified background
character. His intelligent scheming becomes a
confusing and convoluted mess as he simultaneously
plays all sides of the coin. He’s doing baffling
things like throwing away Sansa, turning around,
and making multiple alliances for the sake
of scheming with no real sense of purpose,
and then once all of this clearly wasn’t up to
par for the earlier seasons, David and Dan simply
stopped trying to do anything with his character.
Even when he comes back into the story in season
7, the writers give him such a batshit crazy
objective of getting Sansa to kill Arya that it
makes you fundamentally question if the character
is OK mentally. Not to mention that it’s massively
contrived as to why Sansa is even trusting
Littlefinger at this point. Littlefinger is like
Daenerys in that the writers do something
that utterly compromises the character,
but for Littlefinger, that happens all the way
back in Season 5 when he betrays Sansa. From
there it’s just never going to be believable about
what he does because the writers don’t understand
one of his core principles. Then his death is
such an insult to the character that it feels
like David and Dan pissed all over his grave. It’s
just a depressing death scene because we witness
a character who should be way more intelligent
than this be easily overcome in the most dumb
scheme he ever devised. Him trying to manipulate
Sansa would be like trying to manipulate Ned after
betraying him if Joffrey never killed him. It
flat out wouldn’t work and that’s what David
and Dan commit to for his character. So yeah,
rest in peace Littlefinger. I won’t remember
you for your dogshit ending and instead
your legendary chaos is a ladder monologue.
Number 1, Tyrion Lannister. There seems to be a
trend that my top 5 most ruined characters all
happen to be the most intelligent ones. Maybe
because David and Dan’s intellect wasn’t high
enough to actually write them. But Tyrion to
me was my absolute favorite character and then
he quickly becomes my most hated character. He
takes the number 1 spot by such a huge margin
that it genuinely makes me very angry. So opening
up the can of worms that is Tyrion post-season 4
is basically an entire video in of itself, but
essentially every single characteristic about
him utterly deteriorates. His humor turns into
a juvenile and grating noise that makes my ears
bleed, he’s sucked dry of any energy and charisma,
and his intellect does a complete 180 to the
point that he’s now arguably one of the dumbest
characters. Throughout the entirety of season
7 Tyrion purely exists to just nerf Daenerys
and have her not immediately win the war by
going straight for Kingslanding. Like the more
you think about it the writers just use Tyrion
as a tool to bend the story into the most dumb
directions because he’s deemed as being smart
and people listen to him. The biggest example of
this is his plan to capture the wight which ends
up being completely pointless and a waste of time
and only exists to give the Night King a dragon.
Along with him delivering the worst monologue in
the entire show about how great stories make a
king. Which makes no sense because he literally
knows what makes a strong and prosperous king.
God damn to go from the absolute peak of the show
where he delivers his court monologue imbued with
so much hate and passion, to this abysmal piece
of shit gives you mental whiplash. I really need
to get around to making a Tyrion Lannister
video because there’s so much to unpack here.
By the way, this video was voted on by
my patrons. So if you want to support
the channel and get some rewards then
my patreon link is in the description.
Thank you for watching and let me know in
the comments what your ranking would be.